la gendarmerie a opéré un contrôle de
stupéfiant cet après-midi à la barrière
de phé de monnaie cocaïne héroïne LSD et
cannabis sont recherché par le désormais
célèbre contrôle salivaire passez cette
petite languette là dans votre bouche
vous-même d'accord vous la mettez vous
la frottez au niveau de l'intérieur de
la joue sous la langue et sur la langue
pendant quelques secondes là c'est rose
il faut que ça soit blanc pour bien nous
n permettre de voir qu'il a bien de la
Salie dedans
d'accord tenez je vous laisse le faire
merci
allez-y donc là on presse sur une petite
capsule qui se casse qui se brise il y a
un
liquide qui se mélange à votre
salive vous avez deux barres vers vous
la première celle qui est à votre gauche
c'est la validation du test d'accord
donc normalement il y avoir trois barres
qui vont s'afficher c'est pas que ça
sera positif c'est juste que le test est
valide et que nous on puisse appuyer
dessus d'accord
la seconde barre donc à votre droite
c'est les tests pour vous pour votre
test à vous d'accord donc si elles
apparaissent et que le test est positif
si elles apparaissent pas c'est que le
test est négatif si c'est négatif on
vous rend vos papier vous repartez vous
reprenez la route si c'est positif il y
aura donc une prise de s fa par un
médecin d'accord on va voir ça au bout
de 2 he le dispositif a dû être levé
faute d'effectif car qure contrôle ont
révélé des tests positifs au THC la
molécule active dans le cannabis
hachiche ou herbe cette molécule elle
est détectable grâce à la prise de sang
qui suit le dépistage salivaire positif
la courbe si vous voulez la courbe du
saliv c'est 24 he les courbes de
l'urinaire ou de la prise de sang sont
identi sur et on peutonter une
consommation sur 3 semaines un Mo en
fait le conducteur qui lu qui dit moi
j'ai consommé ce weekend par exemple je
vais faire de la route mardi ou mercred
il peut encore conduire sous l'affluence
du cannabis celui qui conduit c'est
celui qui ne boit pas dit la pub c'est
aussi celui ou celle qui ne fume pas
dans les 24 heures sinon c'est six
points de permis en moins et jusqu'à six
mois de prison avec surcis